what
thanks
hey i'm doing a audio check in the
briefing room
yeah one two one two one two audio check
briefing room one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
audio check from the briefing room
thank you see you later
uh
let's do it
appreciate it
get back there to just fire up
uh
okay
whose camera is this
good
shoulder
oh
okay good much appreciated
thank you
huh
uh
to be nice
so
uh
yes
you'll be fine okay
typically
there's just a lot of activity
uh
okay you see all these things
okay she will move
not a spot for
yep
okay thank you
five
oh
yes
is
i'll leave yeah back then
foreign
okay
um
videos
oh
uh
uh
conference at 5 45. see you in 15
minutes
you just tweeted see us at 5 45.50
you guys
it is so much
we used to go for like two hours
yes
yes
no
um
foreign
oh
just because i have a vacant look on my
face doesn't mean i'm not thinking about
something
fair enough
now
you have to sit here
just checks
that's true
great
nice
for two weeks
you know
yes
i was really i was going strong
um
yesterday
slow down
okay
okay
uh
you guys
yes
charlotte number three
like two weeks before you arrived
is
five
you're filing
um
is
whatever
two minute warning
you must be really wide
oh
so
uh
huh
[Music]
thank you very much
before i provide an update on our
continued progress against the
china virus i'd like to discuss our
latest actions against
the iranian regime
today i'm directing the secretary of
state mike
pompeo to notify the u.n security
council that the united states intends
to restore virtually
all of the previously suspended united
nations sanctions
on iran it's a snapback
not uncommon two years ago i withdrew
the united states from the disastrous
iran nuclear deal which was a product of
the obama
biden foreign policy failure a failure
like
few people have seen in terms of the
amount of money we paid for absolutely
nothing and a short-term deal
this deal funneled tens of billions of
dollars
to around 150 billion to be exact plus
1.8 billion in cash which i don't know
that the president had the authority to
give
gave 1.8 billion in cash just another
great
deal that turned out to be a total
disaster
that would have uh funded all of the
chaos and the bloodshed and the terror
in the region
and all throughout the world and i won't
say anything because i don't like saying
it but iran doesn't have so much money
to give to the world anymore to the
terrorists to give to al qaeda and
various other groups of people that they
were funding they have to
keep their own regime together and it's
not easy for them
and if and when i win the election
within
the first month iran will come to us and
they're going to be asking for a deal so
quickly because they are doing very
poorly
but that deal was a disaster 150 billion
dollars 1.8 billion dollars
in cash and we got nothing except the
short term little deal the short term
expiring is starting to expire
already it's terminated but it would
have
if we didn't terminate it start to
expire very shortly
a good deal was the deal we made with
uae and israel
and by the way other countries i will
tell you now want to come into that deal
countries that you wouldn't even believe
want to come into that deal
and all of a sudden you're gonna have
peace in the middle east and you
couldn't have done it with this
ridiculous
iran nuclear deal as they call it that
president obama made
along with sleepy joe biden i
impose the toughest ever sanctions on
iran
and this has caused great difficulty for
them
giving money to terrorist organizations
and if they do they'll have hell to pay
earlier this year i ordered the strike
that took out the world's number one
terrorist
kasem solomani in addition to previously
terminating
leader and founder of isis abu bakr
al-baghdadi the two
leading terrorists by far
in the world the founder of isis nobody
even talks about that
and we also defeated we now have 100
of the isis caliphate in syria
when i took over it was a mess it was a
total mess it was
they were all over the place my
administration will not allow this
iran nuclear situation
to go on they will never have
a nuclear weapon iran will never have
mark it down
mark it down iran will never have
a nuclear weapon when the united states
entered into the
iran deal it was clear that the united
states would always have the right to
restore the u.n
sanctions that will prevent iran from
developing a nuclear weapon
we paid a fortune for a failed concept
and a failed policy a policy that would
have made it impossible to have peace in
the middle east
here at home through operation
legend we are confronting
the wave of crime in democrat-run
american cities that's
absolutely shocking when you look at
portland or
new york san francisco seattle
chicago sometimes los angeles
democrat run cities they're a mess
because they don't get it
either they don't get it or there's
something that nobody else understands
we've deployed more than 1 000
additional federal agents to
help these democrat run disasters
we just have done this we have to give
them a hand
and we can stop it immediately like a
portland would be
so easy to stop would stop it
immediately we
only sent in some homeland people who
were great by the way to
save the courthouse because it would
have been blown up or burned down
and they did that very easily but if we
were
called upon we would send in whether
it's
homeland whether it's fbi whether it's
just law enforcement
and we'd send them in quickly we would
eradicate it just like
happened in minneapolis as soon as they
were called in they should have been
called in
a lot sooner you would have had far less
damage
today we announced that operation legend
has successfully resulted in nearly 1
500 arrests already bad ones bad ones
really bad people
prosecutions and prison sentences will
follow and they'll be very long time in
prison
for what they've done to these cities
most cities are well run most of the
nation is well run
and the areas that we're talking about
are all in all cases run by democrats
usually radical
radical left leaning
democrats like in new york or in
portland
we've made arrests in kansas city
chicago cleveland detroit milwaukee st
louis memphis and albuquerque for many
violent crimes including
gun crimes arson and 91
murders we're also using the full
power of the federal government to
defeat as you know
the china virus new cases have declined
in 80 percent of the jurisdictions
in the past week 80 percent new zealand
by the way had a big
outbreak and other countries that were
held up to try and
make us look not as good as we should
look because we've done an incredible
job but
they're having a lot of outbreaks but
they'll be able to put them out and we
put them out
the hospitalization rate has fallen in
our country 54 percent
since this peak in april 54
older americans are still the most
vulnerable to the virus
92 of deaths have occurred among those
55 and older
only 2.7 of deaths have occurred among
those 44 years
think of that 44 years and younger so
44 years old and younger
only 2.7 percent of deaths have
occurred and many of those
people had pre-existing conditions they
had problems
heart diabetes and other problems
but uh many of those so think of that
only 2.7
under 44 years of age excess mortality
in europe this year
is 33 percent higher than the united
states
evidence that the tragic cost of this
virus is higher
in other western nations south korea
you've been reading about south korea
doing well well they just had a very big
breakout but they'll be able to solve
the problem
we must all remain vigilant and continue
to exercise extreme caution
around those at highest risk as we know
multiple colleges and universities
announced
that they would suspend in-person
teaching
and we have learned one thing there's
nothing like campus there's nothing like
being with the teacher as opposed to
being on a
computer board it's uh
been proven a lot better it's a lot
better the ipads are wonderful but
you're not going to learn
the same way you do by being there so
nevertheless certain colleges and
universities have announced that they
would suspend the in-person teaching
for older people and individuals with
underlying conditions the china virus is
very dangerous but
for university students the likelihood
of severe illness is
less than
the seasonal flu happens and comes and
it goes and it can be very
bad but people don't talk about it
in the same way and they shouldn't
but if you look at that the odds are
less than or equal to instead of saving
lives the decision to
close universities could cost lives
it is significantly safer for students
to live with other young people than to
go home and
spread the virus to older americans
makes sense
and the shutdown thing
is causing tremendous
depression for those places that are
still
shut down you look at certain areas
that in all cases democrat run
still shut down and the numbers here
aren't even good
but causing tremendous
depression suicide
drugs alcohol abuse
a lot of problems are being caused
probably far more
i would say scott than is caused by the
virus itself now that we understand the
virus
colleges should take reasonable
precautions
students who feel sick should not attend
class and should limit
social interaction as they would for any
other illness
then universities should implement
measures to protect the high-risk
students or professors and teachers
the ultimate goal of testing is to
prevent transmission in high-risk
settings and to prevent transmission
periods but especially in nursing homes
and to care for the vulnerable and our
elderly which really fit into that
definition of who is vulnerable
we have tremendous unused testing
capacity in our country we have a
tremendous
unused testing capacity it's something
that a lot of other nations
are very impressed with they tell us in
our path forward we will continue to
follow a science-based approach
to protecting the high risk well
enabling healthy americans to safely go
back to work in school
our country will be open our country is
getting open quickly or
stock markets are almost back to where
they were prior to the
china virus disaster coming in
and uh i want to thank you all for being
here and we'll take some uh
questions um during the pandemic
uh the q anon movement has been appears
to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say
to people who are following this
movement right now well i don't know
much about the movement other than i
understand they like me very much
which i appreciate but i don't know much
about the movement
i have heard that it is gaining in
popularity and from what i hear is these
are people that
when they watch the streets of portland
when they watch what happened in new
york city in just the last six or seven
months but this was starting
even four years ago when i came here
almost four years can you believe it
these are people that don't like seeing
what's going on in
places like portland and places like
chicago
and new york and other cities and states
and i've heard these are people that
love our country and they just don't
like seeing it
so i don't know really anything about it
other than
they do supposedly like me
and they also would like to see
problems in these areas like especially
the areas that we're talking about
go away because there's no reason that
democrats can't run a city
and if they can't we will send in all of
the federal
whether it's troops or law enforcement
whatever they'd like we'll send them in
we'll straighten out their problem in 24
hours or less
okay at the crux of the theory it is
this belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind well i haven't i
haven't heard that but uh is that
supposed to be a bad thing or a good
thing
you know if uh if i can help save the
world from
problems i'm willing to do it i'm
willing to put myself out there
and we are actually we're saving the
world from a
radical left philosophy
that will destroy this country and when
this country
is gone the rest of the world would
follow
the rest of the world would follow
that's the importance of this country
and when you look at some of the things
that these people are saying
with defund the police and
no borders open borders everybody just
pour right into our country
no testing no nothing you know you talk
about testing no testing
mexico as you know has a very high rate
of infection the wall is now going to be
next week 300 miles long
our numbers are extraordinary on the
border
had that and this is through luck
perhaps more than talent although the
talent is getting it built when one
party refuses to allow it you don't hear
talk about the wall anymore
but i will say this um
we need strength in our country not
weakness
too much weakness yes june mr president
you have been very bullish
on the promise of convalescent plasma to
free coronavirus the fda appeared to be
on the brink of issuing an emergency use
authorization for convalescent plasma
but after hearing from top officials
at the nih that there wasn't enough
evidence to go ahead with that the fda
has put that on
pause your reaction to that and do you
believe that convalescent plasma should
be in
the arsenal of treatments for well i
hear great things about it john that's
all i can tell you and
it could be a political decision because
you have a lot of people over there that
don't want to rush things because they
want to
they want to do it after november 3rd
and you've heard that one before but
i've heard
fantastic things about convalescent
plasma
and i've heard numbers way over 50
percent
uh success and people are dying
and we should have it approved if it's
good and i'm hearing it's good i heard
from people of the fda that it's good
so we'll see i'm going to check that
right after this conference my
understanding that the white house
will encourage the nih and the fda to
get this out there as quickly as the
numbers are as good as i'm hearing i
mean i'm hearing over
50 and that's very good and
we've approved certain things are 31
and that's okay too that's not bad and
it's really had a tremendous impact
uh but uh no i i have uh
you're telling me something right now
that surprises me but we'll check it out
right after this
i don't want delays i don't want people
dying
i don't want people dying yeah please mr
president i want to ask you about your
tweet earlier today on goodyear
it was essentially calling for a boycott
on two-year tires
do you want the federal government to
stop buying
and using goodyear product as well and
is there because what they're doing is
playing politics and the funny thing is
the people that work
for good year i can guarantee you i poll
very well with all of those great
workers in goodyear and when they say
that you can't have blue lives matter
you can't show a blue line you can't
wear a maga
hat but you can have other things that
are
marxist in nature there's something
wrong with the top of goodyear
and what the radical left does is they
make it impossible for people to do
business
if they're republican or if they're
conservative
they put out all sorts of effort don't
shop there
they do vicious things not so different
than what you saw on the streets of
portland two nights ago
boycott do you invest i don't know
that's up to people but
i wouldn't recommend it if they if they
want a whole political speech if they
want to let you
not do what everybody's doing if they
want to wear
a maga hat or if they want to wear a
blue life you know what blue lives
matter right that's police
men and women that's a terrible thing
that's a terrible thing so they're using
their power over these people and these
people want to wear
whatever it is that we're talking about
you know that
and so i would be very much uh
in favor of people that want to buy
there and you know what they'll be able
to
get a good job because we set a jobs
record over the last
quarter as you know the most jobs ever
in the history of our country
you'll be able to get another good jobs
i think it's disgraceful
that they did this please go ahead uh
yes
mr president you've said that the arrest
of jimmy lie
in hong kong is quite a terrible thing
do you have a message for jimmy why has
your administration
spoken directly with him is your state
department working for his release well
i send him best wishes i hear he's a
wonderful gentleman
he's certainly a brave man and
i send him best wishes with that being
said because of that and
obviously what happened in hong kong
we've taken all of the
vast amounts of money that we used to
subsidize
hong kong we essentially subsidized hong
kong by giving them all sorts of
incentives
and that's what made hong kong the
exchange and
business in hong kong successful i've
taken it all back
that means that the united states is
going to do a lot more business you know
we
at we we really gave them tremendous
incentive
and subsidy in order that they be
successful for freedom
but now that the freedom obviously seems
to
have been taken away we will keep all of
the incentives that we were given them
which is billions and billions of
dollars
and all of that business will come into
our country
including the new york stock exchange
and nasdaq
and uh it'll all come here but i feel
badly for him
because i hear he's a good person i
don't know but i hear he's a good person
obviously a very brave person did you
have something good
yes sir thank you mr president uh with
the iraqi prime minister coming in
tomorrow
uh what about the iraqi prime minister
is coming in tomorrow to meet with you
and how do you feel about this notion
that iraq can once again
become the buffer between iranian
influence and russian influence in the
middle east do you feel that under this
prime minister
uh that that's possible once again
this is a man that i get along with very
well we're largely out of iraq we're
down to very few soldiers i said we're
getting out of these endless wars these
uh ridiculous endless wars we should
have never been there in the first place
i think it was the worst decision made
in the history of our country should
have never been there in the middle east
we should have never been
but we're getting out rapidly out of you
know over the course of three years
in getting out it's very sticky getting
out and some people agree and
many people don't agree but i think uh
most people
very much agree uh we're doing very well
in our
negotiations with afghanistan with
getting out we're down to a
much smaller number of people left there
and you know i greet uh men and women
coming home
and coming home after they've been hit
i've also greeted many many at dover
created many bodies coming back in and
uh we've been there 19 years and we're
basically policemen we're acting as
police as opposed to soldiers
and they're going to have to police
their own states and they've been doing
that for thousands of years
but it's time after 19 years that our
soldiers come home they've done an
incredible job but
you know they don't they're not allowed
to fight to win
and and maybe they shouldn't be because
a lot of the people it's not their fault
but with the taliban and with uh
going to iraq again we're we're down in
afghanistan
uh very low numbers and that'll be uh
taking place and
i let them know do anything and you'll
be hit like you've never be
been hit before uh so we're uh we're
doing very well syria the same thing
remember when i took all of the soldiers
off of the
border between syria and turkey right
and everybody said oh this is that was
two years ago it's a long time ago they
said oh this is terrible terrible
terrible we're going to leave why do we
have our soldiers between syria
and turkey turkey can definitely take
care of itself i have a
very good relationship with president
erdogan and
syria has been fighting forever and i
say why are we guarding their border and
i
brought our soldiers back home i got
them out and guess what nothing's
happened
they've been fighting like they have
been for a thousand years okay
nothing's happened and nobody mentions
that everybody said this is going to be
a disaster there's no disaster nothing's
happened
and so we're uh getting out of the
endless wars
and we are building a military the likes
of which the world has never seen two
and a half trillion dollars we've spent
and we hopefully don't ever have to use
it but we want to
focus on a much bigger picture because
we have a much bigger picture
it's uh when you look at what china's
doing when you look at what
russia is doing when you look at what
some other countries are doing
we want to be ready just in case there
is a catastrophe we don't want to see
that we don't want to ever use it
we've rebuilt our military new missiles
new rockets and new tanks and new
everything new everything two and a half
trillion
all made in the usa and we've uh
upgraded incredibly our nuclear
capability and
some of our nuclear needed nourishment
it needed
new strength and we've we've upgraded it
very very significantly
i mean to a level that nobody would even
believe and hopefully we don't
you pray to god we never have to use it
okay
but we've never been in a position where
we've been this strong please
thank you so much um i wanted to ask you
about the middle east i have a couple
questions
um you mentioned that other countries
are interested in following suit
yes having to do with uae and israel
exactly so
is do you expect that saudi arabia will
join
and i do yes and also
the emiratis have expressed interest in
the f-35
do you think that that should be
something that they could look forward
to in the future
is there some sort of timeline they've
definitely got the money to pay for it
you know it's nice because uh usually
when we a lot of times we make deals
they don't have 10 cents
these countries we deal with we give it
to them
like how about paying this back later
but they never pay because they don't
have the money
no they have the money and they they
would like to order quite a few f-35s
it's the greatest fighter jet in the
world
as you know by far stealth totally
stealth you can't see it
makes it very difficult i was asking a
pilot what do you think is better this
one this one that one talking about
russian planes
chinese planes he said well the
advantage we have is you can't see it
so when we're fighting they can't see us
i see that sounds like a really
big advantage to me to these guys
you know they look by the way i said to
these pilots that i meet
they look better than tom cruise
and they're definitely tougher and he's
a nice guy
but these these people are amazing and i
i speak to him
a lot about it what do you think you
know as i go around to the various
places i saved the big one in florida as
an example that was a big one
knocked down pretty much by the
hurricane so uh
i spent a lot of time on that and it's
the greatest plane in the world
uh one thing about that kind of thing
technology high technology
greatest plane doesn't last long
somebody comes up with something else
but we're always the one to come up with
something else
so yeah they'd like to buy f35s we'll
see what happens
it's under review but uh they made a
great uh
a great advance in piece of the middle
east even the new york times thought it
was an incredible deal can you imagine
that
tom friedman had a very nice thing to
say about i spoke to him about it he
thought it was terrific and
and it is terrific i see a lot of
countries coming in fairly quickly
and when you have them all in uh
ultimately iran will come into
there'll be peace in the middle east
that will be nice iran will be
very much neutralized they never thought
this could have happened
and with the horrendously stupid
iran deal signed by obama uh
this could have never happened
on the goodyear issue you ride on
goodyear tires
in the presidential limousine right if
there were an alternative
would you want those tires swapped out
yeah i would do that i would i would
swap them out based on what i heard
we'll see what happens look you're gonna
have a lot of people not wanting to buy
that product anymore
and uh they'll buy from a competitor
made in the usa too okay please
from obama's speech that he will give
later at the democratic convention
um show that he will he says that he
hoped that you would take the
being president more seriously once you
have the job and discover
reverence for democracy and then he said
i quote but he never
did what is your reaction you know when
i listen to that and then i see the
horror
that he's left us the stupidity
of the transactions that he made look
what we're doing we have our great
border wall we have security
we have uh the uae deal which has been
universally praised praised by people
that
aren't exactly fans of donald trump
for various reasons i don't know why
can't be my personality but
they're not fans right and when i look
at
uh what we have now look at how bad he
was how
ineffective a president he was he was so
ineffective
so terrible slowest growing
recovery in the history i guess since
1929
on the economy don't forget until the
china
virus came in we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world
and now we're doing it again i'm gonna
have to do it a second time we're doing
it again
hard to believe we're doing very well
you heard the numbers they're way way
down on the
on the virus but when you look at the
kind of numbers that we're producing in
the stock markets we're almost at the
level in fact nasdaq
and s p are higher than they were
at the highest point prior to the china
virus coming and the plague
coming in now president obama did not do
a good job and
the reason i'm here is because of
president obama
and joe biden because if they did a good
job i wouldn't be here
and probably if they did a good job i
wouldn't have even run i would have been
very happy
i enjoyed my previous life very much but
they did such a bad job that i stand
before you as president
thank you all very much
one two